[Music]
we'll bring you the latest in just
moments from Pennsylvania
but first president Trump famously did
not visit California in his first year
as president with its sanctuary policies
and its hostile far-left leaders Akana
who could blame him
well mr. Trump finally had a valid
reason to go to the Golden State today
where he took a look at the prototypes
of his border wall in San Diego and he
explained why the wall is essential if
you take a look at the fence and it's a
very powerful fence not doing the trick
because they cut holes in it and then
they're patching holes all the time
I'm just looking you have hundreds of
holes cut in and patch so the fence is
not strong enough it's not the right out
here but for those people if you don't
have a wall system
we're not gonna have a country he was
back in the construction site today I
loved it
joining us now for reaction is a CEO who
submitted one of those prototypes
Fischer sand and gravel CEO Tommy
Fischer joins us from Phoenix okay
Fischer sand and gravel you guys have
been in business for I know since 1952
it's a family family-run company and
what was it like to have the president
check out the prototype today oh it was
a great honor for myself and all the
employees and hopefully my dad looking
down from heaven to see where we've you
know come to so to have that opportunity
to demonstrate to the President and all
the people of America of what we're
capable of building it was just a great
honor and I'd also like to thank your
commitment and determination to keep
border security front and center with
all your viewers as well Laura
absolutely well I want to play a sound
byte this is the president you know he
was looking at all the different
prototypes and he made like a running
commentary throughout this is part of it
let's watch we're looking very much at
the wall with some see-through
capability on the other side and then
solid concrete on top or steel in
concrete on top the round piece that you
see up here or you see more clearly back
there the larger it is the better it is
because it's very hard to get over the
top it's really deterrent from getting
over the top who would think who would
think but getting over the top is easy
these are like professional mountain
climbers or incredible climbers they
can't climb some of these walls some of
them they can those are the walls were
not using all right Tommy well which
wall was he talking about because we
were watching sound bite after sound
bite today of individuals who are
against this wall who were saying I can
get over this I've gotten over other
structures before there's no wall they
can make tall enough for me not to get
over because I'm determined to get back
into the United States where I can make
some money or see my family so what
makes your wall impenetrable for the
people who really want to climb it well
first of all Laura our wall is solid
concrete so if you're see-through you
know you're basically a fencer you can
cut like President Trump was talking
about earlier with the
steel and still has its purpose out on
the border but basically encased in our
concrete the biggest difference is is we
took vision very very serious when we
put our proposal together that's why our
walls strong enough to be backfilled so
agents have a 360 degree pan of
panoramic top view down so they have the
advantage and hopefully the president
will get to see that with some of the
other pictures and then the difference
is is we can build through the mountains
as well and we have a product that lasts
150 years it broke my heart today to see
the president talk about fixing wall
that's been out there that's a remnant
wall or something and some of that walls
only been out there or the fence what I
want to say the steel fence 10 years up
to 20 some years and they're replacing
our wall has a hundred and fifty year
lifespan but the big difference with
ours is we can we're building access
roads for the agents so you're not even
getting close to our wall our wall has a
road in front a road behind and it has
such a superior advantage and that's why
we were able to procure the largest bond
in the history of the United States
that's sitting on Homeland Security's
desks that I gave them in January for
ten point seven seven billion like I
talked to you in the radio show to build
700 miles I've also placed a two hundred
and seventy four million dollar bid with
land that I just purchased in California
to build the first 15 miles in the most
rugged mountainous terrain to prove to
the President as well as every American
if you don't have a complete border
protection system you do not have
security and like you said earlier I
take with great respect the president
will if he allows us to play in our team
of Fisher industries to play I guarantee
and no different than Tom Brady once we
get in we never come out and if we don't
perform the president can fire us and
that's how comfortable and confident I
am is when people see what we really
offer I love not taking sides on which
prototype is best but this is why you're
a good businessman a really quick
question how many jobs are we talking
and just really quick what types of jobs
are these good-paying jobs only American
products and only American workers
correct all aamir all American with all
American grit we probably if we did the
big project the 700 miles you're talking
thousands of jobs with us in our
partners the smaller job probably a
thousand jobs
here's the big differences our product
in our patent-pending system does not
need crane so when we go into the
mountains Laura I promise you in 30
minutes you could be running one of our
excavators pulling back those wall forms
and you would see 30 feet of perfect
wall built all right Tommy Fisher Fisher
Sand & Gravel fascinating to see the
president out there was like he's back
on the jobsite and a construction
project thanks so much